I've owned over 2 000 pieces of real
estate in my life I've got several
hundred million dollars worth of real
estate today one thing I know for sure
is if you tell me the renters are going
to pay the payments for you that tells
me you've never managed rental property
that tells me you've never done it
that's a hundred percent you are a
novice at best an idiot at worst and
um I mean that's the truth because
anybody who's ever had a renter and or
been a renter and I have both I've been
a renter too it knows that sometimes
renters don't pay
sometimes there's cancer
sometimes there's car wrecks and job
loss sometimes there's a pandemic
sometimes dot dot dot dot dot
it's you know as if there's a perfect
stream of every month the rent is going
to come on time or early and you can pay
your stupid little payment
and that's the most ridiculous
assumption
which indicates a lack of experience or
knowledge of how rental property really
works